depuis quelques jours on s'intéresse
beaucoup à la Turquie pourquoi c'est
parce qu'il y a eu des élections des
élections très serrées le président
rejet est perdu père douane a gagné
c'est surtout à cause de la position du
président
Erdogan dans le monde qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé
quand je vous disais que c'était serré
ça s'est joué au deuxième tour 52% pour
erdoğan 48 % pour son principal opposant
qui est mal qui est riche darulou c'est
l'union en fait de l'opposition qui ont
donné ce candidat-là contraire douane
mais ce qui a vraiment changé la donne
c'est les ultrasnationalistes 5% environ
qui sont tous passés du côté d'erduanne
au deuxième tour le pays peut pas être
plus divisé qu'il est en ce moment dans
son discours de victoire le président
Erde a essayé d'être pacificateur
unificateur de la Turquie par contre ça
fait complètement abstraction de la
plupart des politiques qui ont mis en
place lui-même dans les 20 dernières
années avec ses alliés conservateurs ses
alliés proches de l'islam radical et ça
va avoir des effets très concrets sur le
droit des minorités la minorité lgbtq+
les droits des femmes également mais
aussi sur la minorité kurde qui existe
en Turquie à court terme le plus gros
défi du président Erdogan mais c'est la
reconstruction de toutes les ondes
touchées par le tremblement de terre de
février dernier
surtout que pendant la campagne
électorale
erdan a proposé de reconstruire 650 000
habitations le coût 100 milliards de
dollars et ça c'est une proposition qui
arrive à un moment où l'économie turque
va vraiment pas très bien il y a une
inflation monstre tout coûte cher et le
président erdan a décidé de garder les
taux d'intérêt bas ce qui va
contre-courant de la plupart des grands
économistes sur la planète qui
recommande de monter les taux d'intérêt
et puis finalement en plus de tout ça il
y a la question des réfugiés syriens ils
sont plus de 3 millions en Turquie
officiellement le président erdouan
parle de retour volontaire
éventuellement Syrie mais le plan en ce
moment du président de Anne c'est plutôt
de construire près 200 000 logements
dans le nord de la série afin de les
renvoyer assez rapidement on peut
certainement questionner la vision et
les projets du président
erdouan mais quelque chose qu'on peut
pas enlever au Président c'est la
position qui l'a su donner à la Turquie
sur la scène internationale et c'est ce
qui fait
parle de lui constamment dans les médias
parce que la Turquie c'est un état pivot
d'abord géographiquement entre
l'Occident et l'Orient mais aussi
diplomatiquement c'est un allié dans
l'OTAN c'est un allié de la Russie c'est
un pays qui donne des drones à l'Ukraine
mais qui est aussi des fortes connexions
économiques avec Vladimir Poutine et il
se pose en médiateur pas juste dans le
conflit entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
mais dans plusieurs autres éléments qui
sont très utiles à l'Occident puis la
plupart des dirigeants internationaux
ont tous voulu rapidement féliciter le
président de Anne que ce soit Vladimir
Poutine ou Joe Biden le président
américain parce que tout le monde veut
s'assurer que la Turquie soit un peu
plus de leur côté de leur alliance et
s'assure de garder un accès à ce pays-là
pivot 6 central dans les relations
internationales en ce moment